PAUL SMITH: And then when they
get to 70, that's where the
big problems start, because the
French haven't invented a
word for 70.
BRADY HARAN: I always assume the
one thing that is kind of
international is numbers,
mathematics.
That's the one thing that
is the same everywhere.
You're about to ruin
this, aren't you?
PAUL SMITH: Yes, I am.
One thing that you learn when
you're studying a foreign
language is that counting
systems are very different.
And, in fact, it's one of the
ways that you can tell if
somebody's a really good speaker
of a foreign language.
You can really tell what their
real mother tongue is when
they start counting, because
even if somebody operates, you
know, an English person living
in France, when they start
counting to themselves, they'll
probably count to
themselves in English.
They're our closest neighbors,
so you'd have thought that
maybe they'd count in
the same way as us.
But one of the things that I
have to keep repeating to my
students is that, in fact,
the French don't
count in the same way.
And they use numbers in very
different ways in a whole
range of different everyday
environments.
Let me give you some examples.
So the French-- well, what do
we do in England when we're
counting numbers?
We give numbers, the first 12
numbers when we're counting,
we give them individual names.
So we go 1 to 12.
And then we slip into a thing
where we go 13, 14, which is
kind of 3 and 10, 4 and
10, and so forth.
The French start off in a
slightly different way.
They go a bit further.
Un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq,
six, sept, huit, neuf, dix,
onze, douze, treize, quatorze,
quinze, seize.
And then they go for our 17,
dix-sept, 10-7; dix-huit,
10-8; dix-neuf, 10-9; and
then vingt for 20.
It's very similar, the
counting system
after that, to English.
So they go on to 20, as
I said was vingt.
Then they go to 30, trente.
Quarante for 40.
Cinquante for 50.
Soixante for 60.
And then when they get to 70,
that's where the big problems
start, because the
French haven't
invented a word for 70.
Instead what they do is they
count to 60 and add 10.
So whereas we go to 60 and then
go to 70, a French person
goes to 60, but then goes to 60
plus 10, because they say
soixante-dix.
Soixante-dix is 70 in French.
Soixante-dix literally means
60-10, but it means 70.
Oh, they know what
the number 70 is.
They don't sort of do
this plus business.
And a French person, when they
hear you say soixante-dix,
they don't think, oh,
that's 60 and 10.
They see 70.
So the mental picture that is
conjured by the sound of
soixante-dix is still 70,
the same as we would.
And then they continue by
instead of say-- they haven't
invented a word, for
example, for 71.
So that's soixante et onze,
literally 60 and 11.
It's rather odd with these
ones that they
say soixante et onze--
"et" is the word for "and"--
because when they get to 72,
they just say soixante-douze.
Soixante-douze, 60-12.
And it's only when we're dealing
with ones that they
use the "et."
But it gets even more confusing
from the English
point of view, because you
think, OK, so we've got
60-10, that's 70.
Soixante et onze,
soixante-douze,
soixante-treize,
soixante-quatorze,
soixante-quinze,
soixante-seize,
soixante-dix-sept,
soixante-dix-huit,
soixante-dix-neuf.
What do they do when
they get to 80?
Surely they've got
a word for 80.
Well, no.
Because the French, when they
get to that number, they say
quatre-vingts, which
means 4 20s.
Well, that's what it means,
4 20s, literally.
The French, of course, when they
hear quatre-vingts, see
80 in their minds.
And then they go
quatre-vingt-un, 4 20s, 1.
4 20s, 2.
BRADY HARAN: Not 4 20s and 1?
PAUL SMITH: No.
They'd just be-- ah.
The reason they don't say 4 20s
and 1 is because it's too
many words.
So there's also a style issue
here, because, you know, the
French love their style.
But what they do do then, and
this is the other weird thing,
when they get to 90, they still
haven't even thought of
another word for 90 or
a decent word for 90.
So what do they say?
They say quatre-vingt-dix,
4 20s, 10.
And then when they get
to 91, they say
quatre-vingt-onze, 4 20s, 11.
92 is quatre-vingt-douze.
93 is quatre-vingt-treize.
94 is quatre-vingt-quatorze.
95, quatre-vingt-quinze.
And so it goes, until
they get up to 100.
And they have invented
a word for 100.
So 100 is cent.
One of the big problems, of
course, with this kind of
numbering system is when you're
listening to somebody
giving you a phone number,
because if
I could just explain--
let me think of an English
phone number.
So you might have 0115, so
that's your Nottingham code.
Then you'd have 962 would be the
subcode for the exchange.
And then the individual
number would be 5782.
And in English, we would read
out all of the numbers,
0-1-1-5, or we might say
0-double 1-5, 962, 5782.
BRADY HARAN: This isn't a real
number, by the way, is it?
PAUL SMITH: No, no.
I just made that one up.
OK.
So that's an example of an
English telephone number.
But in France, they do it
completely differently.
They will take the numbers and
they will say they will
actually distinguish the
numbers 62, 58, 49, 27.
And when you ask somebody for
their phone number, they will
tell you that it is
62, 58, 49, 27.
They won't say--
BRADY HARAN: They'll do that
for all numbers, will they?
PAUL SMITH: They'll do that
for all telephone numbers.
They won't say 625-849-27.
And this causes not big
problems, but if you're on the
telephone to a client in France
who wants your mobile
number and you're used to giving
your mobile number in
the way the English do and then
you try to do it to the
French, they find that very
difficult to cope with.
And it works in the
other direction.
My students are endlessly
telling me about the problems
they had copying down
telephone numbers.
And of course, the really big
problems start when you get to
numbers that start with
a 6, with a 7, with an
8, and with a 9.
So it's a problem, because
if you're English
and you hear soixante--
let's remember that numbers,
what we would call 60 to 69,
start with the word soixante.
But so do numbers 70 to 79.
Let's say that your friend
starts saying "my number is"--
I'll say it in French,
"mon numero, c'est
soixante" you start--
you do that.
And then they say "et onze" and
you have to go back and
correct it, because it's not
soixante at all, it's 71.
But the other thing that the
French do with numbers while
we're on the subject, that's the
French for "10 point 69."
Let's say that that's the world
record for the women's
100 meters dash in
the Olympics.
Now you can see that's very
different from the way that we
would write it in English.
It's also very different from
the way that we would say it.
There we've got a
decimal point.
And the French are
using a comma.
But they also say
it differently.
In English we say "10 point 69,"
because we separate the
tenths and the hundredths.
But the French would
say "10 comma 69."
So you have to listen
now very carefully.
If you're watching a French
sports commentary, for
example, if you're watching the
Olympic Games in France
and you're trying to catch the
time, you have to listen out
for not 10 point 69, but "dix
virgule soixante-neuf," "10
comma 69." So once again,
you've got this issue of
numbers being grouped
together.
And that's something the
French do all the time.
They don't separate individual
numbers out.
They group them and
use their name.
The word the French use for a
comma is "virgule." And they
use that in grammar as they
use it in numbers as well.
So when a French person reads
out this time, then they will
say "dix virgule"--
comma--
"soixante-neuf."
BRADY HARAN: To a French person,
is that "10 point 695"
or is that 10,695?
PAUL SMITH: It's 10,
virgule, 695.
So it would be "dix virgule six
cent quatre-vingt-quinze."
That would be the way
they express it.
BRADY HARAN: How would a French
person write 10,695?
PAUL SMITH: Well, they would
either just do that--
and very often they
leave a space.
In a French textbook you might
find there's a space between
the thousands and the 695.
Or occasionally, this is going
to confuse you, just
occasionally they'll do that.
10,000, full stop, 6-9-5.
So in fact, you could say that
the French and the English do
exactly the opposite thing.
And you could argue that it's
just to confuse each other and
it's deliberate.
Well, I don't have a problem
with it, but it has caused
problems in the past.
There was a rather unfortunate
case in a French hospital a
few years ago where there
was a serious--
too large a dose of something
was administered to patients
simply because of a misreading
of a decimal point for this,
or a comma not being read
the right way round.
So it can be a big problem
in technical translation.
Technical translators need to
be absolutely sure that they
get it right, because
otherwise it can
go very, very wrong.
BRADY HARAN: If you'd like to
hear a bit more about French
numbers, including why it's
impossible to score 20 out of
20 in France, check out another
video we've got here
on "Numberphile." Or if you'd
just like to hear more about
languages in general from people
like Paul and others,
check out another channel I've
got called "Words of the
World." It's got all sorts of
fascinating videos about
things like California
or biscuit or vodka.
There's loads of videos on there
already and there's new
ones going on every week,
so maybe subscribe.